ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Can you
get a sense of the breadth
of Google Cloud Platform
by looking at Compute products
in just a few minutes?
Let's find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Arguably, the Hello
World in cloud
is to provision, start, and
connect a virtual machine.
Google Compute Engine enables
you to create single VM
instances from scratch by
specifying a region, a machine
type, an OS image, and
other optional parameters.
Note how a cost
estimate is provided
while you configure the VM.
A few options that I'd
really like to point out is
the ability to add
GPUs or TPUs-- that is,
Tensor Processing Units--
to your instance, and
the plethora of OS images
that are supported, including
numerous Linux distros and MS
Windows, plus the support to use
a custom image if you see fit.
Once you click Create, give
the system a little time
to boot your instance,
and then you'll
be able to SSH into it
right from a browser.
You could also have
created a new VM
from a previously saved
template or from one
of the numerous, ready-to-go
solutions on the Marketplace.
Now the marketing group would be
upset if I didn't take a moment
and list all the other advanced
features of GC, including
finegrained security
access control,
HTTPS connectivity, truly
stunning live migration
of running applications,
preemptible VMs, and more.
These machines are on
the Google network,
which means that they'll
have minimal latency
and great throughput for
everything that requires
accessing remote services.
Now, one of the reasons that
Compute Engine is so nice
is that it gives you
complete control.
But with that control
comes a great deal
of management overhead.
Thankfully, Google
Cloud Platform
has offerings in the other
side of the spectrum, where
you just focus on code
and we handle the rest.
Of course, we're talking
about Google Cloud Functions.
The serverless flavor
of a Hello World
has to be built on
Cloud Functions.
Here, we provide a
simple snippet of code
to listen to image file
uploads into a storage bucket
to create thumbnails for
each one of them on the fly.
To trigger this
code to run, simply
upload an image to your
bucket and the function
will do the rest.
Now, Cloud Functions
support a lot
of triggers, such as changes
in a database, messages
from pub/sub, or even
Compute Engine instances
changing state.
Cloud Functions can also be
invoked using a standard HTTP
request, meaning a
user visits a URL
and the function does the work.
These functions can be
deployed in any region
from a single
project, and they're
authenticated with the
rest of GCP services,
making integration with
other products and APIs
from the platform
quite natural and easy.
Now here's the best part.
For Cloud Functions
to work, you don't
have to provision a cluster
or deal with server configs.
We do that for you.
And since most of the work
you do with Cloud Functions
is temporal, it means
you only pay for the code
that you're running
while it's running.
No traffic, no cost.
Now, one challenge we
have with Cloud Functions
is that while
they're easy to use,
they make large-scale app
development a little trickier.
So if you need something
larger than Cloud Functions,
but still want
serverless benefits,
you should check out
App Engine, which
has the same scale-on-demand
but a lot more
configurations for developers,
such as services, versioning,
and traffic splitting.
And of course, you can't
talk about cloud in 2019
without talking
about containers.
The Hello World
in container-land
is to deploy a Docker
image to an orchestrator.
Since Google open
sourced Kubernetes,
we've gotten a lot of
feedback about what works
and the challenges involved
with deploying containers.
This led to the development
of Google Kubernetes Engine,
or GKE, a fully-managed
version of Kubernetes.
You can deploy your
containerized applications
to GKE which offers a production
infrastructure guaranteeing
uptime, while providing
rich dashboard metrics
and automated operations from
auto-scaling to node repairs,
to Kubernetes version upgrades.
To deploy a
containerized workload,
simply describe the compute,
memory, and storage resources
your application containers
require, and Kubernetes Engine
will provision and manage the
underlying cloud resources
automatically.
With GKE, you can also
attach persistent storage.
You can even run stateful
workloads such as databases.
You can also make
use of GPUs and TPUs
But best of all, your
Kubernetes workloads
are portable across all
Kubernetes implementations,
from your development
environment to GKE,
to other cloud or
on-premises installations.
In summary, GCP supports all
types of compute workloads.
It will run existing Linux and
Windows applications on Compute
Engine, containerized
workloads on Kubernetes Engine,
and functions or apps on Cloud
Functions and App Engine.
Give us the artifact
of your choice
and we'll provide a fast
and reliable underlying
infrastructure.
Consider taking free code labs
linked in the description below
to explore these
products, and look forward
to upcoming videos on data,
storage, machine learning,
and more overviews.
If you like this video, please
like, subscribe, comment,
and share.
See you soon for another
"GCP Essentials" video.